alright so the dome capture is the
content of the page but we also need to
know how to display the actual page
itself and to do that we need to build a
CSS object model and judging by its name
I guess it's similar to the Dom it's
very close let's take a look okay let's
say we've received the following CSS the
first thing that the browser has to do
is identify the correct tokens but
there's no angle brackets here right
yeah CSS has its own set of rules for
how to identify valid tokens the details
are not that important if you curious
you can check out the CSS specification
link in the instructor notes the
important part is that the parser would
convert the tokens to nodes and in this
case the first would be the body with
its font size property next we would get
the paragraph node and this is the
important part it is a child of body
because all visible content is part of
body weight is that some CSS
specification rule yeah exactly
also note that the children of the body
node inherit its parent styling rules of
16 pixel font size this is what we mean
by cascading rules and cascading style
sheets interesting so it's similar to
but not quite the same as the Dom
construction because CSS rules cascade
down hmm curious let's say I've got a
style sheet with a lot of rules could we
also apply the same incremental
processing trick like we do with HTML to
make the page display faster ah that's a
great question unfortunately we can't we
can't use a partial CSS tree let me show
you why let's say we just received the
first few bites of our CSS and it
contains the two rules we have here so
we go ahead and build the CSS object
model it's tempting to use this tree to
render a page but there's a problem
let's say we now get the next chunk of
CSS and it contains more rules in this
case we have the paragraph
font-weight:normal CSS allows us to
redefine and refine the style properties
this is perfectly valid but notice that
this rule what allow us to change our
CSS on tree and make the text in
paragraph no display with normal weight
ah so that's a gotcha
so you're saying we can't really use a
partial CSS on tree because then it
could lead us to use the wrong styles
when we render the page exactly the
browser blocks page rendering until it
receives and processes all of the CSS
CSS is render blocking